thank you very much I had a very good
telephone conversation extremely good
with Senator Schumer a little while ago
we're working on various elements of the
deal and the Democrats are very much
wanting something to happen and the
Republicans likewise are very much
wanting something to happen and I think
it will I spoke with at length with
Mitch McConnell and this tremendous
spirit to get something done so we'll
see what happens but my conversation was
very good with Senator Schumer I thank
you all for joining us and I'd like to
begin by providing an update on what we
are doing to minimize the impact of the
Chinese virus on our nation's students
with many schools closed due to the
virus the Department of Education will
not enforce standardized testing
requirements very importantly for
students in elementary through high
school for the current year they've been
through a lot they've been going back
and forth schools open schools not open
it's been a little standardized testing
and you know it's we're not going to be
enforcing that so I think you can let
the people know I think probably a lot
of the students would be extremely happy
some probably not the ones that work
hard maybe not but it's one of those
things unfortunate very unfortunate
circumstance we've also temporarily
waived all interest on federally held
student loans they'll be very happy to
hear that and I've instructed them to
take that action immediately and today
secretary divorces directed federal
lenders to allow borrowers to suspend
their student loans and loan payments
without penalty for at least the next 60
days and if we need more we'll extend
that period of time borrowers should
contact their lenders but we've given
them very strong instructions so we've
temporarily waived all interest one
federally held student loans that's a
big thing that's gonna make a lot of
students very happy and we have more to
come when student loans more good news
for the students but we'll do that at a
different time this morning the Treasury
Department also announced that we're
moving tax day from April 15th to July
15th so we're we're moving it out to
July 15th so that people will have time
and people will be able to hopefully by
that time we'll have people getting back
to their lives families and businesses
will have this extra time to file with
no interest or penalties we're getting
rid of interest and penalties however if
you have refunds or credits you would
like to claim you may still file in
other words you can file early if you
are owed money by the IRS other than
that we're moving it all the way out to
July 15th no interest no penalties your
new date will be July 15th today our
team will also provide an update on our
continued effort to prevent the
transmission of viruses America's
borders and I watched what's been
happening in California with governor
Newsom and this morning with Governor
Cuomo and I applaud them they're taking
very strong bold steps and I applaud
them and we're all working together
we're working very closely together
including those two governors but I
would say based on the call the media
was there or I think we can say that
with respect to virtually every governor
in that call I think every governor we
had almost all of them if not all of
them and I would say that you could see
for yourselves at the level of respect
and esprit de corps working together was
extraordinary
there was no nobody angry nobody upset
we were able to help them and that's
what we're all about we want to hell
we're doing things that a lot of people
wouldn't be able to do but the
relationship with governors and States
is I think very extraordinary especially
under the circumstances where this just
came upon us we're working with Canada
and Mexico to prevent the spread of the
virus across North America very closely
you heard what we did yesterday with
Canada and the Secretary of State
Pompeyo will be making a statement in a
little while having to do with Mexico
and the border and she had likewise Chad
willful likewise to be making a
statement there's a joint comprehensive
effort in collaboration with our
neighbors the measure and all of those
measures that we're putting in place
will protect the health of all three
nations and reduce the incentive for a
mass global migration that would badly
deplete the healthcare resources needed
for our people and so we are working
very closely with Mexico very very
closely with with Canada the
relationships never been better we're
all working for the same toward the same
goal our nation's top health care
officials are extremely concerned about
the great public health consequences of
mass uncontrolled cross-border movement
and that would be mostly and even beyond
but mostly during this global pandemic
every week our border agents encounter
thousands of unscreened unvetted and
unauthorized entries from dozens of
countries and we've had this problem for
decades for decades you know the story
but now it's with the national
emergencies and all of the other things
that we've declared we can actually do
something about it would take it a very
strong hold of that and we have before
but this is now at a level that nobody's
ever approached in normal times these
massive flows place of s burden on our
health care system but during a global
pandemic they threatened to create a
perfect storm that would spread the
infection to our border agents migrants
and to the public at large left
unchecked this would [ __ ] our
immigration system overwhelm our health
care system and severely damaged our
national security we're not going to let
that happen so we have a lot of
information and they'll be discussing
that in a moment to confront these
public health degrees the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention has
decided to exercise its authority under
the title 42 of the u.s. code to give
customers a border protection the tools
it needs to prevent the transmission of
the virus coming through both the
northern and the southern borders so
we're treating the borders equally the
northern border and the southern border
it's being treated they're both being
treated equally a lot of people say that
they're not treated equally well they
are as we did with Canada we're also
working with Mexico to implement new
rules at our ports of entry to suspend
non-essential travel these new rules and
procedures will not impede lawful trade
and commerce furthermore Mexico is
taking action to secure our own southern
border and suspend air travel from
Europe so we're coordinating very
closely the air travel going to Mexico
and then trying to come in to the United
States the actions were taking together
with our North American partners will
save countless lives at the conclusion
of my remarks secretary azar secretary
Pompeo secretary wolf we're going to be
also taking some questions with Tony and
Debra who you've gotten to know very
well but they'll be discussing certain
things and I think you'll find them of
great interest we're going to be
providing tremendous amounts of detail
over the coming days but a lot of it
will be provided right now if you'd like
to find out about it there's been a week
of resolute action
tremendous action tremendous
relationships have developed with people
that frankly didn't get along people
that didn't like each other they're now
working together and maybe even in some
cases learning about each other and
liking each other it's nice thing I
invoked the defense production act and
last night we put it into gear we move
the National Response Coordination
Center to the highest level of activity
I mean if you if you take a look at what
we did the level of activation has been
increased to a grade one level which is
the highest level we're providing
historic support to small businesses and
to the states the states need support
normally they do this themselves because
of the magnitude of it the federal
government has gotten very much involved
in terms of getting the equipment they
need so we're helping them it's it's a
responsibility they have but we are
helping the states a lot that's why the
governors I think in every case have
been impressed and very nice we enacted
legislation guaranteeing paid sick leave
for workers at no cost to employers and
I think it's very important so they get
paid sick leave at no cost to employers
we're accelerating the use of new drug
treatments were advancing legislation to
give direct payments to hard-working
families throughout our country
Americans from all walks of life are
rallying together to feed the unseen
enemy strike in our nation in times of
struggle we see the true greatness of
the American character that we are
saying that a lot of people are talking
about it we're in a hundred and
forty-one countries from what they're
telling me and some of those countries
are really working in a unified manner
and they're working very unified with us
almost I could say the good number of
them doctors and nurses are working
nonstop to heal the sick citizens and
churches are delivering meals to the
needy truckers are making the long haul
to keep shelves stopped we've been
dealing with the big store
and the big chains Walmart they've been
fantastic and others they've all been
fantastic we've made it much easier for
them to stock in terms of travel and
travel restrictions were lifting
restrictions so they can get their
trucks on time you're seeing very few
empty shelves and yet the amount of
volume that they're doing is
unprecedented because people want to
have what they have to have what they
feel they have to have and they're also
buying in slightly smaller quantities
which is good because we're not going
anywhere we're gonna be here so I want
to thank all of those very great
companies for working so well Americans
from every walk of life are coming
together and thanks to the spirit of our
people we will win this war we are we're
winning and we're going to win this war
America will triumph and America will
rise higher than ever before we'll be
stronger than ever before and we've
learned a lot we've learned a lot we've
learned a lot about relying on other
countries and I can say that I think in
both a very good and a very bad way some
good things came out of it and some
not-so-good things came out of it so I'd
like to move now to invite our team to
provide information on the new measures
to prevent viral spread at our borders
and I'll start by asking Secretary of
State Pompeyo to speak he's doing a
fantastic job and like everyone else
he's been working very very long and
very very hard and he's doing the other
more normal jobs of a great Secretary of
State but he got he got tied into this
like everybody else and he's been really
doing a fantastic job Mike please
[Music]
Thank You mr. president before I address
the efforts that we've been engaged in
to push back against the Chinese virus I
want to assure the American people that
as president Trump just said your State
Department your entire national security
team is staying focused on the other
diplomatic challenges around the world
those include reducing risk to America
from Afghanistan holding the Iranian
regime accountable for its Mayan
activity and our counterterrorism
efforts against Isis remain a priority
for our team our number-one priority
across those mission sets remains the
protection of the American people the
president our team are very focused on
it I'll take this mo to to thank my team
State Department team who was working
long hours all around the world to take
care of Americans who are stuck in
places around the world I'll talk about
that more in just a minute you've all
seen dr. Burks with me state Department
officials is doing great work but I want
to I want to give a shout out to all of
the State Department team here in
Washington and around the world that are
working overtime to help us push back
against this pandemic under the
president's leadership this week we've
taken two important steps first as
president Trump announced on Wednesday
the United States and Canada jointly
agreed to restrict all non-essential
traffic across our border this decision
goes into effect tonight at midnight the
restrictions will be reviewed after 30
days and they exclude traffic and
movement across the border for work or
other essential reasons we're grateful
to have such an outstanding friend to
the north who has committed as we are to
defeating this virus I also want an
ounce today that the United States and
Mexico have agreed to restrict
non-essential travel across our shared
border both our countries know the
importance of working together to limit
the spread of the virus to ensure the
commerce that supports our economy
continues to keep flowing here to the
United States is glad to have a friend
whose working side by side us in the
fight secretary wolf will talk a little
bit more about the details of how we're
working alongside our partner in Mexico
to keep our southern border safe and
secure as well on another note yesterday
the State Department issued a level-4 of
global travel advisory this means that
all international travel
US citizens should be avoided in
countries for commercial departure
options remain available u.s. citizens
who reside in the United States should
arrange for immediate return to the
United States unless they're prepared to
remain abroad for an extended time if
you choose to travel internationally
your travel funds may well be severely
disrupted and finally I want to talk
about the disinformation that people are
saying well then Twitter around the
world some of it coming from government
some of it coming from other individuals
just urge everyone as they're seeing
information information that at one time
suggested somehow this virus emanated
from the United States Army this
information about lock downs that are
taking place every American indeed
people all around the world should
ensure that where they turn to for
information as a reliable source and not
a bad actor trying to create and flow
information that they know is wrong this
is a tough fight the American people
were tougher our diplomatic teams are
working around the clock to help them
keep safe both home and abroad
and we're showing once again the global
leadership that America has always
delivered it's been great to see
countries around the world well rally
behind what President Trump and our team
are doing thank you thank you thank you
very much we'll take questions right
after this well let me start off by
thanking the president and the vice
president for their continued leadership
and commitment for protecting the
American people during this crisis early
on the president again took
unprecedented actions to restrict travel
from areas affected with the coronavirus
and to date DHS has screened over
200,000 individuals coming back from
those affected countries this has have
been an immense undertaking but one that
the men and women of DHS have
successfully accomplished
today's announcement is yet another
example of the extraordinary steps the
administration is taking to ensure the
safety of the American public before I
comment on the CDC order that I'm sure
secretary azar will later elaborate on
let me first address the progress as
Secretary Pompeo and others have made
with our Canadian and Mexican partners
regarding cross-border travel as we
continue to evaluate common-sense
measures that reduce risk and prevent
further spread it only makes sense
we have looked to look at the measures
that our neighbors to the north and
south are undertaking and so we've been
working closely with those partners
since the earliest days of this virus
and the outbreak and again as the
president said earlier this week in
Saturday Pompeii we've reached an
agreement agreement with both Canada and
Mexico to limit till Lymon non-essential
travel across our land borders let me be
clear that neither of these agreements
with Canada or Mexico applies to lawful
trade or commerce essential commercial
activities will not be impacted we will
continue to maintain a strong and secure
economic supply chain across our borders
a few examples of a central Travel
include but certainly are not limited to
individuals traveling for medical
purposes to attend educational
institutions for emergency response
public health services and individuals
engaged in lawful cross-border trades as
the secretary said the agreements with
both Canada and Mexico will go into
effect on Saturday March 21st
furthermore we're also working
collaboratively with Canada and Mexico
to take decisive joint action regarding
individuals seeking entry between our
ports of entry the CDC order directs the
Department to suspend the introduction
of all individuals seeking to enter the
u.s. without proper travel documentation
that's for both the northern and
southern border the CDC director has
determined that the introduction and
spread of the corona virus and the
department's border patrol stations and
detention facilities presents a serious
danger to migrants are frontline agents
and officers and the American people so
it's important to note that the
department currently apprehends foreign
nationals from over 120 different
countries around the world the vast
majority of those having coronavirus
cases many of these individuals arrive
with little or no identity travel or
medical documentation making public
health risk determinations all but
impossible it's also too important to
note that the outbreak on our southern
border would likely increase the strain
on health systems and our border
communities taking away important and
life-saving resources from American
citizens tonight again at midnight we
will execute the CDC order by
returning individuals arriving without
documentation to Canada Mexico as well
as a number of other countries without
delay
so again CBP is positioned to execute
these measures as we continue to keep
our borders secure and safe before I
conclude let me just wrap up by thanking
the brave men and women of DHS
specifically CBP and across the
government for the work that they do day
in and day out to keep the American
people safe from the coronavirus the
department has a number of frontline
officers that have been tested positive
as well as others who are self
quarantine and that I am doing
everything that I can to protect these
Patriots as they continue to defend our
homeland during this crisis thank you
today's announcement is just the latest
in a long line of bold decisive actions
the president has taken to protect
Americans from the corona virus
spreading across our borders in January
within two weeks of China's notifying
w-h-o about the virus and with only 45
cases in China we began screening
travelers from Wuhan then over time as
the Africa vault the president
restricted travel from China Iran and
Europe our health experts say that these
measures have been truly effective at
slowing the viruses spread to our shores
just think about this Italy and the
United States both saw their first
travel related case of coronavirus
around the exact same time the last week
of January and yet we have had precious
time to continue our work around
vaccines therapeutics and other
preparations while Italy has tragically
been overwhelmed with critical patients
for several weeks now the president
today is taking action to slow the
spread of infectious disease via our
border under Section 362 of the Public
Health Service Act the CDC is suspending
the entry of certain persons into the
United States because of the public
health threat that their entry into the
United States represents this order
applies to persons coming from Mexico
and Canada
who are seeking to enter the country
illegally and who would normally be held
in a congregate setting like a Customs
and Border Protection station it does
not apply to u.s. citizens or lawful
permanent residents during this pandemic
a number of health challenges arise when
illegal immigrants arrive at our
northern and southern borders and are
taken into immigration custody we're
talking about significant numbers of
illegal immigrants from this past
October through February DHS has
processed more than 21,000 inadmissible
aliens at the northern border and more
than 150 1,000 inadmissible aliens at
the southern border
CBP facilities were never designed to
hold large numbers of people and to
protect agents and migrants from
infection during a pandemic nor to treat
them for a novel virus if large numbers
are infected when held at border
facilities these migrants were spreading
the virus to other migrants to CBP
agents and border health care workers
and even the United States population as
a whole in such circumstances the kind
of social distancing measures the CDC
and the president have recommended are
simply not possible on top of that any
resources that we are using to reduce
the risk of infection among CBP agents
health care workers and migrants in
these facilities are drawing on American
an American health care system that is
already fighting the corona virus
pandemic that's why the president and
his administration are taking these
important steps to keep Americans and
our immigration system safe from these
health risks as part of our whole of
government approach to combating the
corona virus thank you mr. president for
the work that you've been doing
throughout this crisis to slow the
spread of the corona virus and to keep
our country safe thank you
[Music]
mr. president so we continue to review
the data very carefully from around the
globe as I know many of you are we
continue to see signs that again
individuals under 20 19 and under may
have severe disease but majority and all
have recovered to date we still see that
same trend and frankly from Italy we're
seeing a very another concerning trend
that the mortality and mail seems to be
twice in every age group of females this
should alert all of us to continue our
vigilance to protect our Americans that
are in nursing homes this requires all
of the community when you see the
sacrifices that many Americans have made
the sacrifices that the service industry
has made to close their restaurants
close their bars and so that the spread
is discontinued and then you really
understand how all of Americans must
make the same sacrifice we continue to
ask you to follow the presidential
guidelines of no groups coming together
of more than 10 that if anyone in the
household is sick that everyone
quarantines in the household together
and that we continue to focus on those
who have the most vulnerability to this
illness now to the moms and dads out
there that have children with
immunodeficiencies or other medical
conditions we don't know the level of
risk and I know you will also protect
them in the same way there just is not
enough numbers at this time to really
tell them if they're at additional risk
are not in the same way that adults are
I don't have any new data I can see the
look on your face is saying is she's
seeing something new I don't have any
new data but I think it's important for
us to be as honest with the American
people as we can and when we don't have
data be very clear that we don't know
finally no one is immune I sometimes
hear people on radio or others talking
about I'm immune to the virus
we don't know if the contagion levels
are difference in age groups but we know
it's highly contagious to everyone do
not interpret mild or moderate disease
as lack of contagion or that you're a mu
immune you just happen to have a better
immune system and the ability to fight
the virus in a way that maybe older
people or people with existing medical
conditions can't and that's why it's
very important at this moment that all
of you carry that message about the
sacrifices that many have made
particularly our service providers and
our frontline health care workers they
making that sacrifice every day so that
every American we can move through this
well but we need every American
following the presidential guidelines
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much mr. president I just want to
underscore a couple of things that I've
said a few times to this group you may
recall that just a week ago or so I said
the two pillars the two elements of our
capability to contain the infection and
the and the surge of infections in this
country rely on two things keeping
infections from coming from without in
we've been very successful in doing that
with China and with Europe now we have
the northern and southern Borden issues
there's a fundamental public health
reason for doing that because we cannot
be preventing people from coming in from
one area when they can actually go into
the other so that's an important reason
understand that there's a public health
reason for doing that the second thing I
think is really important is what
happened in New York today what Governor
Cuomo mentioned about an hour ago some
rather strong issues that have been
addressed with his recommendations not
recommendations essentially orders now
we have a group of recommendations and
guidelines that are applicable to the
entire country
you know them we've been over them yet
there are places region states cities in
this country that are being stressed
much much more than the country as a
whole
clearly one of them was Washington
another one was California
Gunnarsson made some very important
difficult decisions today Governor Cuomo
did the same thing and I want to say i
strongly support what he's doing and one
thing as a new york for myself for those
of you who haven't figured out from my
accent that i'm from new york as in new
york I know what New Yorkers can do
we're tough I was in New York City on
September 11th 2001 and I know what the
New Yorkers can do so please cooperate
with your governor cooperate with your
mayor it's very important thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
Thank You mr. president the White House
coronavirus task force met this morning
we continue at the president's direction
to bring the full resources not just of
the federal government but in full
partnership with our state governments
businesses around America and a
partnership with the American people to
respond to the threat of the corona
virus and I know I can speak on behalf
of the president with confidence when I
say how inspired we are by the way the
American people and American businesses
are coming together to help defeat this
virus in our country millions of
Americans are putting into practice the
president's 15-day guidelines and we
encourage everyone even those that are
not in areas with significant outbreak
to review these guidelines over the next
week and more and put them into practice
and you'll continue to do your part
later today we'll be talking with
manufacturers around the country and
president I continue to be inspired by
the way American industry is stepping
forward we have businesses around the
country that are literally volunteering
to retrofit plants to help us meet the
needs of our health care workers and our
health care system in confronting the
coronavirus as the president mentioned
yesterday following his decision to put
FEMA in the lead the emergency
declaration we actually met with all the
nation's governors from the FEMA
National Response Coordination Center
the President and I our entire team at
the federal level couldn't be more
grateful
for the efforts of all of our governors
in implementing the guidance that is
being issued not only from our task
force but also in taking strong measures
in their own communities to protect
their citizens we want to urge every
American to heed your local authorities
listen to their guidance and and also do
your part to slow the spread we
reiterated to all of the governor's that
the president by putting FEMA in the
lead will continue to implement a plan
that is locally executed state managed
and federally supported that puts the
health of America first we have received
a report today as president mentioned on
our legislative team on Capitol Hill
we're working with Republicans and
Democrats at this very hour to pass an
economic recovery package that the
president described and we hope to see
the Congress act on that early next week
on the subject of supplies we continue
to make steady progress on testing
thanks to the president's involvement of
commercial labs the public and private
partnership more and more Americans are
being tested every single day and
tomorrow
Admiral Gua and FEMA will update the
American public on the status of testing
and our support of state-based testing
efforts that are literally expanding by
the hour on the subject of medical
supplies we continue at the president's
direction to pursue every means to
expand the supply of personal protective
equipment for the extraordinary and
courageous health care workers that are
ministering to the needs of people
impacted by the corona virus we have a
policy of procuring allocating as well
as conserving the resources that we have
in our system and now that the president
worked with the Congress to make
industrial masks fully available for
hospitals to be able to purchase to be
able to use as protective equipment
we're more encouraged than ever about
the availability of those important in
95 mass to our health care facilities
and over this weekend we'll be
announcing a major procurement from the
federal government
n95 masks as well we're also encouraged
that we're finding new alternatives to
increase the supply of ventilators we've
mentioned that we have a federal
stockpile some 20,000 ventilators on on
standby but that doesn't count the tens
of thousands of ventilators that are in
our healthcare system around the country
but the president has challenged us to
work to free up other ventilators from
other sources around the country and
there are two different ways that we're
doing that number one in our recent
discussion with anesthesiologist we've
literally identified tens of thousands
of existing ventilators that can be
retrofitted and converted to be
ventilators for people struggling with
the coronavirus but also on the
president's behalf on behalf of all of
our task force we want to continue to
urge every American and every American
hospital and healthcare facility to
postpone any elective medical procedures
this will free up bed space free up
hospital capacity for people that are
struggling with the coronavirus and
it'll also free up equipment that our
health care workers need it is inspiring
that we continue to receive reports of
businesses around America are donating
and ninety five mass to their local
hospitals businesses large and small or
donating hundreds in some cases millions
of him ninety five mess and I know I
know how grateful the president is and
we all are and let me close by saying as
all of our experts have said many times
while the threat of serious illness to
the average American from the corona
virus remains low every American can do
your part to reduce the burden on your
health on your family the burden on our
healthcare system and especially the
threat to the most vulnerable among us
by putting into practice
the president's 15 days to slow the
spread and as the president said at the
outset of his remarks I know that
millions of Americans are doing that
just now and the greatness of the
American character is shining forth
thank you Mike thank you very much okay
thank you had a call Senator Schumer he
says you've now agreed to invoke the
defense production act to actually make
those medical supplies that hospitals
say for in severe shortage so two
questions is that what you're doing now
it is I did it yesterday
we invoked it I think the day before we
signed it the evening of the day before
and invoked it yesterday we have a lot
of people working very hard to do
ventilators and various other things yes
using it now to tell this we are using
for certain things that we need
including including some of the very
important emergency I would say
ventilators probably more masks to a
large extent we have millions of masks
which are coming and which will be
distributed to the states the states are
having a hard time getting them so we
were using the act the act is very good
for things like this we have millions of
masks that we've ordered they will be
here soon we're having them shipped
directly to States you were signing this
but not invoking it this is what you
said yesterday and you would only do so
in a worst-case scenario so we know we
we need no it's no different other than
we need certain equipment that the
states are unable to get by themselves
so we're invoking it to use the powers
of the federal government to help the
states get things that they need like
the masks like the ventilators yesterday
more consideration to a national
lockdown and keep people no I don't
think so essentially you've done that in
California you've done that in New York
those are really two hot beds as it
probably the two hottest of them all in
terms of hot spots I don't think so
because you go out to the Midwest you go
out to other locations and they're
watching it on television but they don't
have the same problems they don't have
by aunt by any means the same problem
New York California Miami the governor
is doing an excellent job governor
DeSantis in Florida we have some pretty
hot spots in Florida too but we're a
general and the state of Washington of
course but that was largely if you look
at it it was one nursing home that had
problems like you wouldn't believe
so now we're working with the governor's
and I don't think you'll I don't think
we'll ever find that we'll have to see
what the results are at the end of 14
days let's say well know by the 15th day
to see what we do but I'm certainly
honored by the way the American people
are working because it's work it's work
not to work this is the first time this
has ever happened and we're working out
a tremendous financial package for them
so they don't work who ever heard of
this usually you work out a financial
package to get people working we're
asking people not to work the social
distancing that new term that's become
probably the hottest term there is so no
I'm very honored by the way the American
people are taking this image so
seriously yes Jeff a question for you
and a question for dr. factory if I
could
there's been some concern among
Democrats on Capitol Hill that the phase
three fiscal stimulus has waited too
much in favor of corporations and not
enough in terms of individuals what did
your conversations with Senator Schumer
yield on that for though I think that
really all of that is being discussed
right now we talked about as an example
buy back stock buybacks I don't want to
have stock buybacks I don't want people
spending I don't want some executives
saying we're gonna buy 200,000 shares of
stock I want that money to be used for
the workers and also for the company to
keep the company going but not for
buybacks I would I mean I haven't spoken
to a lot of the Republicans or Democrats
owner we discussed it and I I don't like
buybacks I didn't like them the first
time are you suggesting we're discussing
that with discussing many things on the
same page from Saturday we're not so far
away
that's a we're not very we're not very
far away and to dr. Khatri if I could
dr. Kashi was explained yesterday there
has been some promise with
hydroxychloroquine this potential
therapy for people who are infected with
chronic virus is there any evidence to
suggest that as with malaria it might be
used as a prophylaxis against Cobra - no
the answer is no and and the the
evidence that you're talking about John
is anecdotal evidence so as the
Commissioner of FDA and the president
mentioned yesterday we're trying to
strike a balance between making
something with a potential of an of an
effect to the American people available
at the same time that we do it under the
auspices of a protocol that would give
us information to determine if it's
truly safe and truly effective but the
information that you're referring to
specifically is anecdotal it was not
done in a controlled clinical trial so
you really can't make any definitive
statement about it
without seeing too much I'm probably
more of a fan of that then maybe than
anybody but I'm a big fan and we'll see
what happens and we all understand what
the doctor said is a hundred percent
correct it's early but we've you know
I've seen things that are impressive and
we'll see we're gonna know soon we're
gonna know soon and including safety but
you know when you get that safety this
has been prescribed for many years for
people to combat malaria which was a big
problem and it's very effective it's a
strong it's a strong drug so we'll see
effective against disarms it was very it
was as I understand that I is that a
correct statement it was fairly
effective when SARS
John you've got to be careful when you
say fairly effective it was never done
in a clinical trial that compared it to
anything it was given to individuals and
felt that maybe it works too well that's
the point whenever you do a clinical
trial you do standard of care versus
standard of care plus the agent you're
evaluating that's the reason why we
showed back in Ebola why particular
interventions worked
about the possible therapies yesterday
mr. president you said they were for
quote immediate delivery immediate we
heard what an ordering yes we have
millions of units ordered bear is one of
the companies as you know big company
very big very great company millions of
units are ordered and we're going to see
what happens we're going to be talking
to the governor's about it and the FDA
is working on it right now the
advantages that it has been prescribed
for a totally different problem but it
has been described for many years and
everybody knows the levels of the
negatives and the positives but I will
say that I am a man that comes from a
very positive school when it comes to in
particular one of these drugs and we'll
see how it works out Peter I'm not I'm
not saying it will but I think that
people may be surprised by the way that
would be a game changer but we're gonna
know very soon but but we have ordered
millions of units it's being ordered but
from Bayer and there is another couple
of companies also that that do it there
is no magic drug for coronavirus right
now which you would agree I think we
only a little sorry I physically maybe
and maybe not
maybe there is maybe there isn't we have
to see we're gonna know is it possible
that your impulse to put a positive spin
on things
maybe giving Americans a false set
okay so I think that I think it's gotta
look it may work and it may not work and
I agree with the doctor what he said may
work may not work I feel good about it
it's all it is just a feeling all right
you know I'm smart guy I feel good about
it and what you see you're gonna see
soon enough and we have certainly some
very big samples of people have you look
at the people you have a lot of people
that are in big trouble
and this is not a drug that obviously I
think I can speak for a lot of it from a
lot of experience because it's been out
there for over 20 years so it's not a
drug that you have a huge amount of
danger with it's not like a brand new
drug that's been just created that may
have an unbelievable monumental effect
like kill you
we're gonna know very soon and I can
tell you the FDA is working very hard to
get it out right now in terms of malaria
if you want it you can have a
prescription you get a prescription and
by the way and it's very effective it
works I have a feeling you may and I'm
not being overly optimistic or
pessimistic I sure as hell think we
ought to give it a try I mean there's
been some interesting things happened
and some good very good things let's see
what happens we have nothing to lose you
know the expression what the hell do you
have to lose okay
scared though I guess nearly 200 dead
14,000 you're sick millions as you
witness who are scared right now way to
say to Americans we're watching you
right now you're scared I say that
you're a terrible reporter that's what I
say
I think it's a very nasty question and I
think it's a very bad signal that you're
putting out to the American people the
American people are looking for answers
and they're looking for hope and you're
doing sensationalism and the same with
NBC and Comcast I don't I don't quote
Comcast I click Comcast let me just have
for whom you work let me just say
something that's really bad reporting
and you want to get back to report a
good set of sensationalism let's see if
it works it might and it might not I
happen to feel good about it but who
knows I've been right a lot let's see
what happens John connected back to the
science and the logistics the units that
were ordered are they for clinical
trials are they for distribution to the
general patient population we are going
to as I understand it we are going to be
taking samples in New York Governor
Cuomo very much is interested in this
drug and they are going to work on it
also after they get a certain approval
we're waiting for one final approval
from the FDA we'll see what happens
but we'll use it on people that are not
doing great or even at the beginning of
not feeling learned fallen under then
John what do we have to lose so this way
John it's been out there for so long we
hear good things let's see maybe it
works and maybe it doesn't just they
gave the application here so that would
be under sort of a modified
compassionate access we're doing that I
guess and that's that's what it's called
you know yes to follow up on what the
president is saying should Americans
have hope in this drug right now and sir
I would like to follow up on Peters
question here
could you please issue address Americans
in this country who are scared right now
this is a very valid concern people have
really isn't that much of a difference
in many respects with what we're saying
the president feels optimistic about
something his feeling about it what I'm
saying is that it might it might be
effective I'm not saying that it isn't
it might be effective but as a scientist
as we're getting it out there we need to
do it in a way as while we are making it
available for people who might want the
hope that it might work
you're also collecting data that will
ultimately show that it is truly
effective
and safe under the conditions of covert
19 so there really isn't different it's
just a question of how one feels about
it
believe it's not safe well certainly as
a drug any drug John has some toxicities
the decades of experience that we have
with this drug indicate that the
toxicities are rare and they are in many
respects reversible well we don't know
is when you put it in the context of
another disease whether it's safe
fundamentally I think it probably is
gonna be safe but I like to prove things
first so it really is a question of not
a lot of difference it's the hope that
will work versus proving that it will
work so I don't see big difference this
year to do their jobs your message my
message to the American people is that
there is a very low incidence of death
you understand that and we're gonna come
through this stronger than ever before
if you get it if you happen to get it it
is highly unlikely it's looking like
it's getting to a number that's much
smaller than people originally thought
in terms of the ultimate the ultimate
problem which would be death my message
to the American people is number one
you've done an incredible job
incredible what you've gone through spin
and crit wasn't their fault wasn't their
fault it wasn't the fault of a hundred
and forty other countries where this has
happened and there is tremendous hope
and I think we're going to come out
stronger better bigger in every way I
think we're going to be a better country
than we were before we learned a lot we
learned on reliance who to rely on who
not to rely on but our country our
country has been incredible the way they
pull together including the fact that I
just spoke to Senator Schumer we had a
wonderful conversation we both want to
get to a good solution but it's been it
really for me watching and seeing people
that weren't speaking getting along well
because we all have one common aim and
that's to get rid of this invisible
enemy get rid of it fast
and then go back to the kind of economy
that we had and maybe even better
worried about how long it'll take
we're gonna be focused a big focus and
including my conversation with both
Mitch and with Chuck a big focus of that
conversation with small businesses
because they are really the engine
behind our country more so than the big
ones they are the engine behind our
country are you concerned about members
of Congress that may have used
information they learned on updates to
sell stocks and profit off this I'm not
aware of it I saw some names I'm not oh
I know all of them I know everyone
mentioned dianne feinstein i guess and a
couple of others i don't know too much
about what it's about but i find them to
all be very honorable people that's all
i know i think and they said they did
nothing wrong i find them the whole
group very honorable people yeah please
the whole group would include richard
burr the head of the intelligence
committee and it also would include
senator kelly Lafleur and so the
question is whether or not they should
be investigated for that behavior but it
also includes dianne feinstein a
democrat you didn't mention her name why
didn't you mention her name and i think
she's a very honorable person by the way
so i'm not say but you know it's
interesting that you mentioned two
people but you don't mention one that
happens to be a Democrat because i have
to look at it possibly but i find them
to be honorable people yes
you see yourself as a wartime president
right now leading the country through
this pandemic that were experiencing do
you really think you know going off on
Peter going off on a network as
appropriate in the country is going
through something like I do because I
think Peter is you know I dealt with
Peter for a long time and I think Peter
is not a good journalist when it comes
to fairness I think the country has to
understand that there is indeed whether
we like it or not and some of the people
in this room won't like it
there's a lot of really great news and
great journalism and there's a lot of
fake news out there and I hear it all
and I see it all and I understand it all
because I'm in the midst of it so when
somebody writes a story there's a story
on television and I know it's false I
know it's fake and when they say they
have 15 sources have said and I know
there's no sources there's no sources
they just making it up I know that and I
call Peter I call Peter F but I call
other people out too and you know this
is time to come together but coming
together is much harder when we have
dishonest journalists it's a very
important profession that you're in it's
a profession that I think is incredible
I cherish it but when people are
dishonest they truly do hurt our country
almost two months ago why did you say if
you could have known earlier and also
you have been calling I can speak for
myself but I have a very good
relationship with China and with
President Xi I have great respect for
President Xi I consider him to be a
friend of mine it's unfortunate that
this got out of control it came from
China got out of control some people are
upset I know I know President Xi he
loves China he respects the United
States and I have to say I respect China
greatly and I respect President Xi I
never like stock buybacks from their
standpoint when we did a big tax cut and
when they took the money and did
buybacks that's not building a hangar
that's not buying aircraft that's not
doing the kind of things that I want
them to do and we're now talking about
buybacks we didn't think we would have
had to restrict it because we thought
they would have known better but they
didn't know better in some kid not in
all cases obviously some people did an
incredible job they built plants all
over the country I mean you'd see what's
happened I mean we were doing until this
invisible enemy appeared we were I mean
we never had an economy like this but
there was some companies that used that
money to buy back stock driving up the
price of the stock artificially in many
cases I don't like that I don't like it
and as far as whether or not we'll have
that allow them when we give them money
because we have to keep these great
companies in business because of the
workers frankly for the most part
because of the workers the workers are
my number one concern but the way we
take care of the workers is we have to
keep the
but he's going I am fine with
restricting buybacks in fact I would I
would demand that there be no stock
buybacks I don't want them taking
hundreds of millions of dollars and
buying back their stock because that
does nothing yep
Secretary of State buffaio is extremely
busy so if you have any question for him
right now could you do that because you
know what I'd like to do I'd like to him
to go back to the State Department or as
they call it the deep State Department
you don't mind I'd like to have him go
back and do his job so does anybody have
any questions on work travel you need to
find that this all works with anyone
with the work visa can still cross the
border can you define the measures
you're taking it's a great question
we'll we're working with very real
concern about h-2a visa particular
agricultural worker need to get across
we're gonna make sure that we do
everything we can to keep that part of
our economic lifeblood working between
our two countries DHS and the State
Department will work together we want to
make sure and keep commerce between
Canada the United States and Mexico
alive functional and prepared for the
day that this economy bounces back like
we expected it well
mr. secretary the Mexican government has
not announced any travel ban on Europe
word have you been you talked with them
as to when they're gonna do this and
what it is that they're telling you and
then a second question they also are
telling us I'm said in a press
conference this morning that they will
not take back any non Mexican citizen
any other third parties will have to we
don't know what will happen to that so
can you address what will happen to
those third country immigrants that you
are saying that will not be allowed to
enter the US and Mexico saying that they
will not be allowed to stay in Mexico
either or sent back from the US I'll
take the first one in the chat I'll give
you the second one with respect to
travel into Mexico from outside I spoke
with foreign minister abroad a couple of
times about this I'm very confident
we're gonna get to a really good place
that protects the Mexican people and the
American people from those who might be
travelling into places where we've got
designations the Schengen zone from
China so that they're not coming in to
Mexico and then coming into the United
States I'm very confident we'll do that
we'll make that announcement shortly
together as we implement the cdc's order
again we're gonna take a number of
individuals that cross the border
illegally and repatriate them or remove
them quickly back to Mexico back to the
northern triangle and back to any other
country so we're gonna do that in a
rapid fashion we'll continue to work
with Mexico to make sure that Mexican
nationals go back as well as other
populations sending what a mile
inspector what a mile or Cubans back to
Cuba what would you do those third
countries that are not Mexicans so we're
doing all of the above we're gonna be
sending it again individuals back to
Mexico individuals back to the northern
triangle countries Cuba Haiti all the we
again 122 different nations that we see
- analogies that come across that border
we'll be sending them back individually
to their countries but also with working
with Mexico to send additional
populations back there as well
stupid you know when you said before you
said they're non Mexicans going to
Mexico we are not sending them to Mexico
we're sending them back to their own
countries not to mix it why would Mexico
take people that are from Mexico we're
sending them back in the case of
Guatemala Honduras El Salvador a lot of
other countries they go back to the
country from where they came
okay and Mike please the issue of
disinformation is there any particular
locus for this disinformation or is it
diffuse it's pretty diffused
unfortunately but we've certainly seen
it come from places like China and
Russia and Iran where there are
coordinated efforts to disparage what
America is doing in an activity to have
to do all the things that President
Trump has set in motion here other than
what you're doing this morning what are
you doing to fight back things lots of
work one of the things one make sure is
the American people go to trusted
sources for their information but we've
made clear we've spoken to these
countries directly that we don't that
they need to knock it off that we don't
approve of it and then there are a
handful of other things were engaged in
to make sure that the right information
is out there and accurate information is
given this this idea of transparency and
accurate information is very important
how we protect American people from
something like this ever happening again
people to be coming to trusted sources
of information does it undermine you at
all when the president stands up here
and the attacks news outlets calling us
have a question these volunteers have
all have the sort of Peace Corps
military Americans who find themselves
stranded in places where there are no
longer flights to get back to the United
States what efforts are being made to
help them appreciate that question so
we're doing lots of things we've had a
couple places in particular Peru and
Morocco I think we've had the first two
maybe three now flights out of Morocco
what we're gonna work to get people back
we're urging individuals when they can't
get back on their own they traveled
they're on their own when they can get
back they're on their own they ought to
try it to do that but we are we have a
team stood up at the State Department
the repatriation task force that is
working each of these instances so we've
heard from individuals members of
Congress we're trying to get Americans
back from these places where air travel
has been disrupted now and we will get
that done over time we'll get it done
successfully
we don't know the full scale of it yet
but we think we have the largest number
identified and we're working if there
are those who are watching that are
someplace and you can get up you can go
on the State Department website you can
log in to get step gov and go step and
login and we'll we'll track it and we'll
try to get everybody back - how long are
these border restrictions likely to last
on the south and north borders well as
long as we need to do it to protect the
American people from the rest I couldn't
tell you how long it's going to watch we
have you have you determined whether
Iran is responsible for that rocket
attack last week
so maybe we shouldn't show you so let me
just let me just get back to you on the
answer to that and what we get what we
can say what we can say with certainty
is we've made clear all along that the
Iraqi Shia militias are fun to trained
equipped by the Iranians and we've urged
the Iranian not to do that we've told
the Iranians that they will be held
responsible for those attacks when they
threaten American lives the Peace Corps
volunteer that are in 60 plus countries
had they'd all been returned you know I
don't know if they're all back or not
yet I know that they were directed to
come back I know that most of them
Rebecca couldn't type if we have all of
them back in and sanitary secretary
Gasper is not here but to get the tests
to the troops in Iraq and Afghanistan
were you able to give us a progress
report on the status of that if they're
already able to get tests I don't know
the answer to that I know we have State
Department officials to who are
concerned want to make sure we get them
tests our team as well we're working on
that we've had significant success on
that to date there are a few places
we've not been able to get them but we
will we'll get them there how exactly
are you gonna get those Americans back
and do many plans to get the military
involved in that we can use all the
tools we can these first efforts are
combined commercial private flights that
will fly in bring them back bring them
back to a destination here in the United
States so we'll do that there are some
that will travel back other ways as well
and we've worked with the Department of
Defense to say where there are is space
available we'll be able to bring them
back on those flights as well it's the
old government effort to make sure we
get them back again they're gonna help
us every place they can secretary that's
where I've talked about a couple times
pushed on or on again
he's reconsideration
relaxing sanctions on Iran during the
first part that's a question the whole
world should know that humanitarian
assistance into Iran is wide open it's
not sanctioned we offered to provide
assistance to the Iranians as well I
talked with dr. Ted Rose from the World
Health Organization about this we're
doing everything we can to facilitate
both the humanitarian assistance moving
in and to make sure the financial
transactions connect to that can take
place as well
there is no sanction on medicines going
to run there's no sanctions on
humanitarian assistance going into the
country they've got a terrible problem
there and we want that humanitarian
medical healthcare assistance to get to
the people of Iran sanctions themselves
we are working to do all the things
we've had in place for the first three
years here to deliver security for the
American people they know the end all
right they know the answer arrest the
leaders they know the answer to your
question
work with the president for three years
now I know how much he values the people
that work on my team I know when I was
the director of the Central Intelligence
Agency how much he valued the work we
did I know that he watches our team dr.
Brooks all the team that's working to
push back against this virus to keep
America safe I know how much he values
them the CDC picked up but there were
some sort of virus happening in wool on
the corona virus happening in new home
as early as December when did the CDC
start letting other agencies know that
there was something in China happening
that this piranha virus was happening
and then when did the whole government
approach pastor to happen so I let the
CDC or the factories are pleased yeah
yeah so so we were alerted by some
discussions that dr. Redfield the
director of the CDC had with Chinese
colleagues on January 3rd it's since
been known that there may have been
cases in December not that we were
alerted in December there's been some
discussion about China and what they
knew and when they knew it and I've been
very critical we need to know
immediately the world is entitled to
know the Chinese government to know of
this risk to the world and that puts a
special obligation to make sure that
data that data gets to our scientists
our professionals this is not about
retribution this matters going forward
we're know we're gonna live exercise
here to get this right we we need to
make sure that even today the datasets
that are available to every country
including datasets that are available to
the Chinese Communist Party are made
available to the whole world it's a it's
an imperative to keep people safe we
talked about the absence of datasets not
being able to make judgments about what
to do this is absolute or this
transparency this real-time information
sharing isn't to visit about political
games or retribution it's about keeping
people safe and so when you see a
Lyonne information flowing from the
Chinese Communist Party to the technical
people who we wanted to get into China
immediately to assist in this every
moment of delay connected to being able
to identify this risk vector the risk
vectors creates risk to the people all
around the world and so this is why it's
not about blaming someone for this this
is about moving forward to make sure
that we continue to have the information
we need to do our jobs mr. secretary
what what message do you think it sends
to other countries when you have the
present United States lashing out at
reporters I've had my frustration with
reporters too all I ask when I talked to
the media is that you listen to what we
say and report it accurately and it's
frustrating it's frustrating when you
see when you see what you see that
doesn't happen it's enormous ly
frustrating we have a responsibility to
tell the American people the truth and
those who are reporting on what it is
we're doing and saying have an equal
responsibility to report accurately many
things that the State Department
reported wildly and accurately on
multiple occasions and I have spoken to
those reporters about it each and every
time and I will continue to do so they
got warned about mr. president
that's all right mr. secretary senator
Johnson has suggested that you and the
administration may be overreacting he
said we don't shut down our economy
because tens of thousands of people die
on the highways we don't shut down our
economies because tens of thousands of
people die from the common flu at worst
three point four percent of Americans
will die from this virus he said what do
you say to people that have that view
that's 11 million people he's talking
about well I just say the entire world
is agreeing with us because their rope
they all have their choice and
everybody's doing the exact same thing
we want to shut it out and we can do
that and we'll see what happens in two
weeks and three weeks but if we can save
thousands of lives and even millions of
lives potentially you don't know where
it goes but you could be talking about
millions of lives so if you look at the
the world I mean you have some very
smart people in the world you have some
smart leaders in the world and
everybody's doing it the way we're doing
it I think we're doing a better job than
hopefully most if not all we're doing a
very effective job but we'll we'll know
better in 14 or 15 days but you know
you're talking about hundreds of
thousands and maybe more than that
numbers of people and you know we can
bring our finances back very quickly we
can't bring the people back there are
millions of people out there that share
that view that say I don't really need
to shut things down I don't really need
to stay away from stores I don't I can
go to the beach and those people making
multiple actions exponentially it's the
difference between life yeah I agree
with it but I think I'd like to have
Anthony answer that because to be honest
that's what he does and he we had a lot
of a lot of very talented people telling
us what they think we should do Thank
You mr. president first of all I think
that's a false equivalency to compare
traffic accidents with I mean that's
totally way out that's really a false
equivalency when you have something that
is new and it's emerging and you really
can't predict totally the impact
it's gonna have and you take a look at
what's gone on in China and you see
what's going on right now right now in
Italy and what's happening in New York
City I don't think with any moral
conscience you could say why don't we
just let it rip and happen and let the X
% of the people die I don't understand
that reasoning at all will be leaving
any other questions Thank You mr.
president
two things in New York this is a
doubling every day they fear that
supplies are going to run out in a
matter of weeks yesterday
Mayor Bill DeBlasio called on you to
mobilize the military to deliver urgent
supplies yesterday he said quote the
fate of New York City rests in the hands
of one man here's a New Yorker and right
now he is the Train the city he comes
from
I've personally spoken to emergency
department nurses who say that they're
being told not to wear n95 masks because
supplies are so low so how do you
respond to those remarks by mayor de
Blasio I'm not dealing with dealing with
the governor and the governor agrees
with me and I agree with him so far
we've been very much in sync I I guess
they're not agreeing with each other
necessarily but the relationship with
New York I Love New York I grew up in
New York as you probably have heard and
the relationships were very good and I
think government and the governor have
been getting along incredibly well with
the federal government okay
Thank You mr. secretary welcome I could
just on on illegal entries people who
are otm how will the turn back process
work will they be taken to a common area
and then put on a plane and syphax in
northern countries or others I mean how
would that process work yeah it's a it's
a public health crisis so what we're
trying to do is limit the the amount of
contact that we have with these
individuals not putting them in Border
Patrol facilities ice detention
facilities and like so it's going to be
very rapid we're gonna obviously take
them into custody and then and then send
them back to a port of entry or other
means so it'll be very quickly it won't
be the six or seven or ten days that we
currently have it'll be much more rapid
TM will you will they be take you to it
and your field that's right that's
correct proposed tiers of checks Frank I
believe believe in a lot of things I
want to get workers money and whichever
way the best way to get it and I want to
keep the businesses open - because
without the businesses they're not going
to be getting money for very long but
we're gonna be we're gonna be threatened
if they'll do something later I'm sure
Wall Street analysts are predicting the
unemployment numbers from skyrocket next
week by some analysts say as many as 3
million people applying for unemployment
which would be a historic number of one
week spread so he's a thousand dollar
check going to cut it exactly we're not
talking about a thousand dollar check
we're talking about much more than that
we're also talking about doing phases if
this doesn't work we're gonna keep doing
until we get it going and frankly once
we get the economy back and once this
enemy is defeated the invisible enemy as
I call it once it's defeated we get the
economy back it's gonna all come back to
us very quickly it comes to back very
quote we have a tremendous economy we do
numbers like no other country has ever
done before number one in the world if
you go back to weeks and still obviously
but if you go back to week's number one
of the world by far that money comes
back to us very rapidly we want to keep
it we want to have it so that when we're
not if but when we win the war with the
invisible enemy when we win it these
companies can immediately start not that
they have to start rebuilding which
takes a long time Stevens for job losses
in March and April are you hearing
looking at different numbers we have a
best-case and a not best case but the
big thing is to defeat the virus once
that virus is defeated Steve I think
everything else falls in place very
rapidly I think you're gonna have a
tremendous upswing a lot of people agree
with me a lot of if you look at your
stock market geniuses and some of whom
are not geniuses but they think they are
a lot of people think that I'm right
about that that once we defeat the
t-virus I think you're going to have a
very steep like a rocket ship it's going
to go up and everything will be back and
I really believe we're going to be
stronger than ever before yeah go ahead
on the issue of supplies you pull
governor's to try to find whatever
supplies they get on their own some of
them are now saying when they go to try
to buy them they're being outfitted by
the federal government well you heard my
news conference yesterday was sort of
yesterday's news no well that does
happen because they want to buy supplies
we want to buy as a backup to them in
case they can and sometimes that will
happen but regardless of who gets them
when they need them we're getting them
to them now we're doing the production
act we're doing it very much and we have
a lot of things cooking right now at a
high level
remember this nothing like this has ever
happened before over a hundred and forty
countries and you have supply chains
that are broken down for two reasons
because they can't supply that much and
because people are sick and they can't
be on the chain so you have a lot of
interesting things all over the world
you have supply chains that broke down
because of the illness and also because
of the fact the quantity but we're
getting it ordered we're getting it done
and the if you just have to look some of
you were at the call yesterday where I
spoke with the governor's almost all of
the governors and every one of them was
very impressed with what we've done I
would have to talk to are you saying
that the administration is requiring
these industries to create these
products for just asking so far we
haven't had to it's an amazing thing
that happened we're getting calls from
automobile companies we're getting calls
from other companies saying they have
plant capacity they want to make
ventilators they want to make other
things we are literally being besieged
in a beautiful way by companies that
want to do the work they want to do the
job they want to help us they want to
help our country so we haven't had a
problem with that at all
president how do you help out states and
localities that are trying to bid on
things like ventilators and other items
that are being outfitted by them well
when they call us they let us know if
there's a conflict they will call us and
we will drop our bid because we want
them to go first because their point
that point of sale so we've had four or
five instances where literally that was
happening because you know we're both
trying to get stuck and if we're going
against they will call us the smart ones
frankly will call us and we will
immediately we want them to buy it
because it gets to them quicker if they
buy it they know that and it's happening
more and more where they're calling and
they say we're bidding against each
other they want to get it they'll get it
much quicker than there are labs across
the country that don't have the testing
supplies they need what specific actions
we've made a good thing I haven't heard
that question well but go ahead
yeah so first we're making tremendous
progress in terms of lab testing tens of
thousands of tests are being done every
single day both through the CDC and the
public health labs as well as now
through the private sector commercial
labs they're getting to scale they have
supplies they have high throughput we do
hear anecdotally occasionally of say a
public health lab or another one that
has a concern about this supply or that
supply through FEMA we actually are
standing up a laboratory task force to
answer those questions usually it's that
the lab people do not understand that
there are actually alternative supplies
in the marketplace that they are
perfectly free to use we've actually had
to put out some common myths and truths
about that for instance the other day we
were getting calls from governors saying
we don't have swabs there no swabs there
are no swabs our supply people went in
the open marketplace and bought 200,000
swabs in the open market and I just sent
a letter to every governor sending them
swabs so some of it's just they aren't
listening or checking with us about all
the freedom all the capacities out there
it's a complex system with 330 million
Americans and all of these labs so
sometimes there's a lab that doesn't
understand how much flexibility they
have and how much supply there is out
there and we're working through the new
FEMA integration Center to help correct
that for folks well as I said more and
more tests are being performed every day
and as we learn about the results that
are being reported around the country of
coronavirus tests our experts continue
to look at the numbers and see that some
90% of Americans that are tested do not
test positive for the coronavirus and so
it can give you a sense of the magnitude
of testing that's going on we have the
number of cases that we've reported
today but it's it's in some cases near
to ten times that that have been tested
but let me also emphasize how important
it was in answering these questions for
governors and local officials that the
president stood up FEMA and the National
Response Center where we briefed
governor's yesterday now every governor
and their State Department state health
departments have the ability to reach
out with to our regional FEMA
administrators and that's how as the
president said we're sorting out those
potential conflicts between very
significant federal purchases and
procurements and and as hospitals and
state governments are purchasing as well
I think the new streamlined system
operating now in all 50 states and our
territories of Governors and states
going through their Regional
Administrator for FEMA is going to make
it more possible for us to ensure that
our hospitals our health care providers
have access to what's available on the
open market and elsewhere
the task force you've seen the numbers
you've spoken average Americans you're a
former governor what do you say to
Americans right now we're watching and
who are scared I would say do not be
afraid be vigilant all the experts tell
us that the risk of serious illness to
the average American for the corona
virus is low but we need every American
to put into practice the president's
coronavirus guidelines 15 days to slow
the spread because the corona virus is
about three times more contagious than
the flu according to our best estimate
and you can contract the corona virus
have very mild symptoms if any not even
be aware that you have it and expose
someone who is vulnerable to a very
serious health outcome that's the reason
why we're encouraging people to avoid
groups of more than 10 to not eat in
restaurants but to use drive-throughs to
wash their hands on a regular basis and
particularly we're going to continue as
the president has directed us to focus
on the most vulnerable population which
are seniors with serious underlying
health conditions or anyone with an
underlining immunodeficiency it's those
people we need to care for but it's
going to take all of us working together
to make sure they're safe you just said
that you haven't had to require
companies to up their production of
medical supplies but you've said last
night you invoke h-tpa
when we need something when we need
something because
the act when we need something we order
something and as you know two days ago I
invoked the Act which was a big step I'm
not sure that it had been done before
certainly not very much and when we need
something we will use the act what has
happened is before we even go out many
many companies great companies companies
in a totally different business are
willing to do things and make things
because that's what they do they make
product they're willing to make product
for us medical product that we need very
badly for the states that the states
can't get they haven't been able to get
and you know most of the states in no
way did they do anything wrong they were
stocked up they were all equipped
unfortunately they've never had a thing
like this so they need help from the
federal government you haven't actually
directed any companies to start making
more ventilators or mr. prisons
partially following up on that are there
auto makers right now who are retooling
their production facilities to make
ventilators or I can't say they are but
they will be very shortly because we're
working with one in particular the ones
to make ventilators they called us
yesterday and they were already well
working on a transaction they're gonna
make ventilators they say they've done
it before which surprised me but they
can do it very easily
this is personal you know partially for
secretary AIDS are you said yesterday
that you had spoken to Carnival
corporation's chairman yes and he said
that he could donate some shoes and
still make this I'm not giving them he's
not like you use them
I spoke with Micky Arison who's the
president chairman CEO and owner he said
he said to me that he was willing to if
we need ships if we need ships for
helping people that carnival would be
absolutely willing to help us in Los
Angeles in New York wherever they may be
in Miami with every big if we needed
something that would be willing to so
far we haven't needed to and we're
bringing the big hospital ships up in
California we haven't we're working with
the governor of California's you know
with Gavin and we haven't made a
determination we're also talking the
folks would like it in Seattle so we're
we're discussing where it can be most
useful we've spoken with Governor Cuomo
and we're bringing the big hospital ship
up in two weeks and we're gonna have it
in New York Harbor some place in New
Yorker so my question is one I don't
think you haven't taken them up on you
yes right now we don't have a lot of
frequently contacted surfaces and so
this is where you come in secretaries
are potentially dr. pouchy you have
concerns about those youth worships
being uses hospitals so I can tell you
they're very clean and also those
services that the German as you know the
virus disappears over a period of time
and these ships are very clean they've
been kept very clean they've been gone
over but the virus as you know of it's
on a surface for a certain they have
actually charts different kinds of
services it disappears over a period of
time what are you trying to get it the
the virus disappears when it's on
surface after a certain number of days
or in some cases hours depending on the
surface
follow up so can you say you name any of
the companies that you've asked to start
making these ventilators on Facebook I
will be but first I want to get the
approval from the company because I
don't want to be doing that
I assume they'd like it but I'll let you
know okay we'll take in this for dr.
Falchi UH one company that has openly
stated it is General Motors I didn't
speak to them about announcing it but
I'll announce it I'm sure they wouldn't
be but we have others also thank you and
so forth dr. pouchy there's new research
out rooms that the CDC has released that
many of the people that have or that 13%
of the people with the coronavirus got
it from someone that was asymptomatic so
my question is does that change the way
the approach that should be taken and do
you think that's the phase or do you
think that or do you not do that
research the the recommendations that
are here applies to whether you're in
physical contact with someone who could
be infected with symptoms versus
asymptomatic I don't really think it
changes anything certainly there is some
degree of asymptomatic transmissibility
is still not quite clear exactly what
that is but when people focus on that I
think they take their eye off the real
ball which is the things you do will
mitigate against getting infected no
matter whether you're near someone who
is asymptomatic or not it's the same
thing physical separation and the care
that's outlined here is going to take
care of both of those things
I have a question about testing when
will every American who needs a test get
a test and wouldn't be able to get a
test and why not
have medical equipment being shipped
right now hospitals you're hearing very
positive things about testing and just
so you understand we don't want every
American to go out and get a test three
hundred fifty million people we don't
want that we want people that are
assisted that have a problem that have a
problem with the air sneezing this
sniffling they don't feel good they have
a temperature there are a lot of
different things you know you know I'm
better than I do so ready we don't need
that but what we are having is we're
having these private labs have come and
they've been really fantastic and we
also have a great system for the future
because as I said we inherited we
meaning this administration an obsolete
broken system that wasn't meant for
anything like this now we have a system
that you can see because look we'll well
into this and nobody's even talking
about it except for you what says it
surprised everybody to go out and get a
test because there's no reason for it
yeah
people who is now suggesting that their
real way to get to the end of this for
life to return to normal is for every
single person living in this country to
be tested that way you could see who's
contagious and you could then have
people who don't have it back into work
is there any possibility that this
country could ever get to a point where
every single person could be tested and
how long would that take it thank you
for the question I've heard that before
I don't see I don't connect the dots
there I don't see how testing everybody
in the country is gonna help you to
implement this this should be
implemented universally at least at this
level for everyone
the things we spoke about a while ago
that you want to really ratchet it up
like governor Newsom is doing in
California like Governor Cuomo is doing
in New York or how you put an end to
this outbreak testing is important it
would be nice to know and there are
certain things you could do but let's
not conflate testing with the action
that we have to take whether or not you
test do this I'm not I'm not putting
down testing as an important issue
but people seem to link them so much
that if you don't have universal testing
you can't respond to the outbreak you
really can after listening to Tony and
everybody else that's an expert I do
think it's important that not everybody
be tested if you feel great and if you
have no symptoms whatsoever
it's it's a it's just not a good thing
to be doing right Steve
you mentioned the possibility of aerosol
transmission of the virus how likely is
that to happen that the possibility of
aerosol transmission always comes up
when you have situations like that it
comes up with influenza it came up with
SARS in which there was a documented you
know one-off episode of some aerosol
transmission aerosol means that it can
stay in the air for a period of time
because it's in a droplet that's very
small and doesn't go down
is it possible and that there is aerosol
transmission
yeah if certainly is but clearly what we
have seen in the situations where people
have gotten infected from the areas that
we have experienced China South Korea
now Europe most of it is in a situation
where people are close enough to each
other that a symptomatic person will
have a real droplet transmission so I'm
not ruling out the possibility that it's
aerosol but again it's not gonna
substantially change doing this what is
the demand pressure on testing in this
country and are we meeting I get the
same calls that many of you get that
someone goes into a place who has a
symptom and wants to get a test and for
one reason or other multiple logistic
technical or what-have-you they can't
get it that is a reality that is
happening now is it the same as it was a
few weeks ago absolutely not because as
the secretary and others have said right
now that we have the private sector
involved the availability not only just
availability but the implementation of
the availability is getting better and
better and better having said that I
understand and empathize with the people
who rightfully are saying I'm trying to
get a test and I can't that way of
saying we are not yet at a point earlier
well the answer is yes John we are not
there yet because otherwise people would
be never calling up saying they can't
get a test well I just can't emphasize
enough about the incredible progress
that we have made on testing all of your
reporting and media outlets around the
country are as well that that many many
more tests are being performed every day
literally by the tens of thousands and
this has only been made possible because
several weeks ago the president brought
in the commercial labs these enormous
companies quest and LabCorp working with
companies like Roshan and Abbott
Laboratories and thermo Fisher and said
we have this existing system of state
laboratories and the CDC processing
tests for certain infections but given
the magnitude of this outbreak the
president a pre hend it early on that it
wouldn't be enough to meet the need and
I just want every American to know that
literally hour by hour in partnership
with these extraordinary commercial labs
we are making more and more tests
available every day we'll detail the way
that we're working with States to
distribute those tests we've obviously
focused on states that have been dealing
with with the most serious outbreaks of
coronavirus Washington state California
New York and others we've been making
sure the tests are in those areas
working closely with those governors but
I think the American people should be
encouraged at the progress that we are
making tomorrow we'll take some time to
detail that progress for you but I would
say to any American who might be
concerned that they have symptoms as the
president said so well we we don't want
every healthy American to get a test but
if people feel that they have symptoms
that they identify with the corona virus
call your doctor their doctor can call
their state health authorities that can
work very closely with
our entire team through HHS and FEMA and
work to identify the more and more tests
that are available every day just just
so you know just for the hundredth time
I this administration inherited an
obsolete broken old system that wasn't
meant for this we discarded that system
and we now have a new system that can do
millions of people as you need them
but we had to get rid of a broken old
system that didn't work it worked only
in a very limited basis and we're very
proud of what we've done
it's incredible what we've done and this
system will now serve for the future for
future problems hopefully you don't have
a problem like this but something will
come up we have now a great system and
it's almost fully in gear but it's able
to test millions of people but we
inherited a broken old frankly a
terrible system we fixed it and we've
done a great job and we haven't been
given the credit that we deserve that I
can tell you but the one that really
just